extreme Aussie Aussie where we live you
I think you can't oh yeah yeah we laughs
okay
we is a guide YouTube in a building
everything's going to get the tweets out
first minutes we sell we look a little
slow loads just bear with us a lot of
things going on tweets is going on you
don't get that shout out to the cars
going by
alright and I believe we are laughs
welcome to the i lords podcast and the
Lords of gaming dotnet episode number
130 and it's another glorious Sunday
we're back at the roundtable on the
Lord's Day and we've got someone getting
knocking on a door Project X Club Veda
impresses outer world console parody
gears 5 is an MPD flop its game pass
working and switch your three to discuss
so we gonna get right into it
so let's introduce well we got four
shots up the three horsemen of gave me
buckos with the co-host my brother
mother the difficult game Conqueror and
the half of the young wolf mommy Lord
had a guy do sir
I'm still over here waiting for my intro
King I still demand a premium intro out
to some premium premium lawyer to check
my boy can't match that he looks too
cold with fire a super check i'ma let
y'all start but which three is the best
game of generation early early pastor
West pastor he's a pastor now yeah man
that did forget to say Lord of reviews
so addict is correct I did not give him
the premium sauce listen right now
magneto seems to be a little bit off oh
do you wanna start this over attic I
mean because like I mean really be
honest with you he does treat everyone a
whole lot better
we do it we do it you know we fear I
talked to my union representative
yesterday okay he said you're full of it
yeah we want equal pay for equal work
we give you service they do it dirty
right now man what you can play an
addict man it's good destiny to some
debts three two or more destiny to 9:55
so of course I'm brother solve this
after diamonds last minute call out man
we hope he is okay worked has summoned
him they have beckoned him the mean
Tucker shout out to Sovereign than me
Tucker you say that what he's not here
[Applause]
the XS gamer ooh the lord of combat
sports king of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert pointment
Oh beloved look a guy you do exam I'm
doing fantastic let me tell you boys
yeah crazy crazy crazy what's gonna
judge man in the back right that is he
is the biggest is that is that is that
what you're gonna look like when you go
in on solver know what I'm gonna go take
his knees is gonna be mad easy like I'm
gonna show your stache
it's not mad Surgical when I snatch his
kneecaps off I got that backward
compatibility
well I've been playing a little bit of
destiny a little side order of destiny
and a whole bunch more
from yesterday no down all better all yo
reinforcements carry the rail you know
shout-out to all these lords who come
through because I'm a huge fan of their
content they always hold us down I
consider these three true friends to the
realm so let's get all of them start off
first of all it kiss move jumping off Oh
what's up iron Lords man what's up
Cognito King David attic of course
shout-out to you guys you guys have been
doing it major you know so it's been
good to watch I had except me I'm an
invite I got that home just in time so
y'all can't be no y'all if you weren't
Cognito I'd be bad I just like I like it
I really do like it right hook to me but
I just realized right and this is before
I even I never and I realized never use
it I gave my sister a desk LED light for
her for a dorm room yep that's just as
bright as his brain it costed me like 10
frickin bucks bro like you know I'd be
kind of tight I'd be tweeting all about
going in or me no I like you I enjoy it
it's a nice setup
I've never liked I use it every day it's
like I turn off all the lights on me any
other lights running while it's on and
whatnot but I just I I was like you know
I would have never purchased this like
if I like nobody was but people were to
shouted to Lord advantageous now that
they were like yo you need
what is it doing there's no special it's
gonna on the side okay that's what you
was talking about when you hit me up
from there oh oh oh hold on before we
get the stress today there's rel mrs.
shout out to Lord dizzy man with the
finalist super chair just because solve
is not present it is not a reason to
forget that kid goes deeds and with
recent rumors we want them clean their
wax but I think we need a pause that he
wants another man to wax his knee Oh
dizzy and I know you've gone through it
but I'm a fraud alert dizzy I need you
to sit there with this on your head
double-barrel gaming's
oh my bro oh man I I saw the flare get
shot up this morning and of course I had
to respond it was a 1013 before the iron
Lords podcast and I came running in my
in my charger to make sure that I slid
off the top of the hood like we did in
the 70s we do we doing this toski a hot
you go to man down we have we have a
lord down
104 coming through in our darkest hour
to hold this down for saw how are you
doing man we haven't talked in a while
yeah no we uh I've been playing one of
the games that hasn't scored very well
but I just I got about 30 or 40 hours
into it that's Ghost Recon break points
I can't stop playing that game I was a
huge fan of of wildlands I mean I got
1,000 out of 1000 achievements in that
game and I knew that just based on what
the game looked like I was gonna enjoy
you know what it is I think people or
gamers more so are just disappointed
they want the old Xbox 360
you know go freak on you know whether
you had the team before and it was those
tactics with with everything based on
technology you know the old the old good
warfighter and I think I gotta be honest
with you you know usually we hear in
media the the publisher will respond not
just to a score but to the out cries of
the people and I really think that
moving forward a Ubisoft is gonna have
to return to the warfighter days in some
fashion because I don't yeah I don't
think that the wildlands you know yeah
the formulas actually working for that
it works for me but I think people want
the old-school stuff boom boom back they
do yes you can't play actually all of
them that's right it's one of the few
places you can't play it so so shout out
to all you frauds out there that's
complaining go out there and go buy the
new 60 game and if you got it just pop
it right in because Microsoft does that
for you who did definitely said console
doesn't have it doesn't have a card
swiper when it when you need to do
back-to-back you don't have to slide
that card it serve up those knees
breakpoint going on pretty much out yeah
I've been playing a lot of breakpoint I
actually reviewed was given us 11 bit
studios sent me out of code for children
of morta which I would be talking about
a really good publisher yeah they're
great
they put out a lot of really good stuff
so I was very fortunate for them to send
me a code and I'm going to be doing the
review live actually to start out our
primetime gaming on Monday evening
they'd say people that are made on they
made a new blames us for actually they
have a game out now that some people may
be into Frost punk is also something
it's more like a survival / strategy
type of yo did y'all play that game is
on um on game pass and it's like yes um
Norse mythology dude running around with
a javelin and it's like yo yo and you it
is one of the bloodiest games going
right and it's like a side scroller and
as you're going you have to throw the
javelins and bust people in the face
worm right that's the color Foley you
know because you actually wolves are
planar and I you know how I say I had to
try one game this game is absolutely the
as me on something I think is called I
got a double check but i'ma look through
my phone right now well as you're
walking you're throwing the javelin and
you can hold it down and is split into
three and they got flying things flying
at you and they send giant ogre's at you
and you gotta hit the guy okay I with
the spear and he goes yes with all this
game pass thing I think you sell a gate
pass better than Xbox be doing right now
listen I'm waiting for them to send me
that check and I'm gonna put on a
spandex suit wall punch people in the
mouth and say gig dang can can I stop
coming out there I'll be your Robin oh
we could pull up
I've been doing all of this oh no but
but but but if it's Cory Enix and they
want to talk about you know Final
Fantasy 7 remake my wear spandex and of
course I see now the Lord in the
building the basement radio arcade
podcast himself Enrique who is muted how
are you doing sir I am doing very well
that's fine Sunday morning I'm here with
the Lords I got the call from Laura
Cognito is actually actually asleep
believe it or not yeah I had a long day
on Saturday we we went down to DC and
stayed the night got on like 6 o'clock
in the morning it's just brutal but I'm
here and I'm looking forward to talking
some videogames with you fine gentlemen
this great Sunday morning so yeah happy
to be here man experience in gaming
himself so um yeah I just wanted to make
a couple of things known first option
playing shadow keep you I know that we
ain't even got to get too deep into that
that's what it's been going on but
obviously we're gonna talk about X cloud
cuz you boy been rocking getting that
little controller thing action that's
nine up to this bad boy get it rocking
we'll discuss that later
yeah just real quick your CEO was out
last night shouts Dominic Reyes looking
fantastic
got Chris Weidman up out of there with
the quickness notice can think I'm gonna
lift my head up for that they go get him
and he's a different dude make it up in
there and don't let him have some of the
funny sauce you let Bones blow line
either before the I'm gonna keep it on
the funny sauce so he go get in there
and do the LeBron in the beginning
if you can I do we missing the beginning
of the fight fantastic performance you
know just like I said you like the fact
II stuff to wrestling why men regardless
of whatever it being small that he has
like world-class wrestler so that was
nobody see but anyway as you know the
Lord's are lovers of the superjet we
always love those words in color but we
have a special need a special request
kinda like a call to arms for you guys
man because um as you know our brother
dizzy he is going through it right now
and I'm gonna put some in the chat for
you guys just like I said to make
everyone aware you'd understand
obviously you know the Lord's take
cancer very very seriously and um you
know our brothers going through the next
round
he's an AIDS fight he's got his xbox out
there so I just put it in the chat I
gotta say you know we appreciate all
that you guys do and actually I don't
know why it's not going through the chat
but we're gonna try again oh it's too
long what I'm gonna do is add it I'm
gonna send it to you and um if you can
put that through so we can get this in
for dis man cuz this is important I want
to know a couple of things when it comes
to dizzy um first of all he's editor in
chief of lords he gave a dotnet alright
and he works as hard as anybody else and
you would not know that he is going
through this ordeal that he is uh you
know dealing with this and like you saw
he was in he super chatted early and
he's he's here every Sunday he supports
so hard so we would need everybody to
galvanize together to support I don't
care if you don't send any money today
here send the money did dizzy you know
will read the chat I don't care um I
read it if it's not in color just just
really support this man because um I
didn't know how severe and serious
everything was because he doesn't lead
on to that he's not saying why me he's
not you know crying about the situation
he's dealing with he's bucking up and he
is a true soldier so let's all galvanize
behind dizzy and let's let's show this
man our support this
Lord of the realm he's a true Lord
appreciate ya I sent you the link
directly if you can put that in the chat
for me brother it won't let you go let
me all that's right because you think so
you know I'll just retweet it you know
I'm saying and you know what yeah you
yeah you can also add it to the show
notes so people at the end if they after
they listen to the show can head over to
the show notes and just click the link I
gotta tell you you know I watch you guys
show every week and I'd say this and I
don't save Clem on the on the show today
you guys are by far and it is being a
content creator are one of my personal
favorite shows to look forward to listen
to every week and when you see this fine
gentleman given those super chats and
the way he talked you would never know
that he was dealing with some serious
stuff so big salute to him for battling
something that is a very tough situation
and and him to be here each and every
week goes to show not only is he well
you know a Superman in my opinion but
the fact that he doesn't put that in
front of what his love of gaming is
unbelievable absolutely I also if you
guys check the oh my LP Twitter you know
I'm saying I'll actually put it out
right now again so again guys well it's
like I said anything towards they said
him the family you know the cares is
real you know say our brother is going
through it and like I said he's just so
his spirit is strong I'm saying yeah the
day we just want to show them that love
that support if we can and that's what I
wanted to say man so on that's what I
got 49 super check good morning look
good morning to you thank you so much yo
well well I really think you're onto
something and you know it is good right
now the name of the game that I'm
talking about
it's Lich spear double spear edition
it's crazy it's something that is goofy
it's fun it's something that you'll put
on your player for
couple of minutes it's outstandingly fun
it's just it's just some real goofy fun
stuff that you'll enjoy rocking last
week poll results are in and the people
have spoken to the question with the
recent announcement and details of ps5
hardware do you think project scarlet
can afford to have less power or equal
to PS 5 power in performance the winner
of the 3-way ILP poll with 52% of the
vote is yes xbox quality games from
their studios from next-gen supplants
the power narrative group come in at
second place and only 35% of the vote
was the know if PS 5 is more powerful
then that is the death blow to scarlet
at know much last place is surprising
13% of the vote is I don't care
stay Diaz negative light latency will
surpass all hardware gaming consoles
salute to all hold those who participate
in the poll ok got me laughing so Lord
gig what do you think sir
I think they order something but I'm
gonna tell you something about that
stadia stuff like that stuff right there
the negative part whoa
these guys out here today in full effect
um listen I don't agree with the pol III
believe that if the PlayStation is more
powerful than the Xbox digital foundry
is gonna do exactly what they did
this generation and report the facts if
they come in and they showing 8k
anything and Xbox ain't showing 8k
nothing I don't care about low refresh
later on I know I don't want to hit it
and you know what and I know you
watching mr. Phil Dominus Maximus
Spencer if you want that Aurelius attach
to the back in your name and I knew you
want that Aurelius attached to the back
your name I need you to come out here
with the pimp slap and I need you to
make sure that their scarlet is way more
powerful than that PlayStation 5 kick
what's the power Darin if Kayla's that's
right salute you know say oh sure the
price of power
yeah - sleepy goblin want to hear your
thoughts you know I'm saying definitely
appreciate it but uh no no you missed
i'ma stitch guess did for me yes they
fully realize to read well first of all
stitch six six six nine drops an
outstanding and extremely generous
twenty dollars uber Chetan he says I am
always here listening and following the
nonsense but when it's time to support a
fellow gamer you can count all you can
count me in salute Lord Disney thank you
so much but I do thank you brother
realist money please again check the IOP
Twitter like I said we had that
information out there and we really
really appreciate it Madison this is
love you already know so that's what's
the pole man so we gonna get into this
thing man we got a lot of topics to
discuss but first jumpin off man on
Project X cloud man first of all anybody
beside myself did anyone have access to
the beta so far just want to go to the
bush no no that I thought was gonna get
in they send me an e-mail like commutes
are wanting to confirm my t-mobile
account I'm like oh yeah I'm in cuz yeah
slow-mo backslap got the same email and
then he got in the next day and me
nothing no oh yeah I have a sprint so
I'm gonna probably get it on the backend
okay don't you mean what it is is they
have the kid they got the the deal with
them as I'm sure he so it's not a
cross-promotion thing so those are
they're working together you see that
Xbox is definitely trying to work with
some eyes P so it looks like t-mobile
for the u.s. is gonna be a little
connecting I don't know why they chose
them but they must clearly have that
relationship the deal is they're working
with our ISP to make sure that they can
facilitate to those customers to take
that people come in if you know the
t-mobile is doing that that might be the
power switch right there that might be
the move to get you over that might be
the reason why you get rid of your
iPhone and throw it in the bushes
knowing that you know just Android might
get you in you might run over
t-mobile right now oh let's get to it
man obviously your boy he's got the
access he's been rocking you know like
the person that didn't get that Evo is
the only person that actually got it
already not like him I do not like him
at all
people keep thinking that you know
what's messed up I know the whole back
story behind it and I'm stationed right
now I'm not gonna expose him you know
I'm making a Jim Jones him and tell the
truth I'm not gonna Jim Jones you what's
going on all strings Cognito the rundown
I've been rocking for about two days
straight really put this thing to the
test and um yeah man so first let's get
the bad out the way all right first off
if y'all got this right the Bluetooth
syncing with um Xbox with the up with
Android devices please make sure you
have one of these controllers that has
the Xbox Live button that actually is
one unit as opposed to this the elite
you see how the elite the Xbox Live
button is kind of like a separate unit
on top do you don't have bluetooth you
will not be able to connect this this is
right so that was the first mistake on
me so just getting bluetooth gone was a
bit of a chore so I got that rocking
because I had a essa touring with that
now the other thing I was going to say
is that they're gonna need some
accessibility options because as you
were playing it'll screen it's very
small fonts are very small you know
that's a little bit of a pet peeve also
shout-out to addict notifications
they're gonna need a way that when
people texting you that it does not
overlay on your screen because addict
was folding my ex class a couple it's
with his Texas of his message so dad you
gotta find a way to disable that you
know them saying and then um yeah is
there a way to just say well
might be a phone thing you're right that
might be me but I was mad that I kept
seeing the overlay okay talking to me
while I'm trying to play I go along I
used to do that do that to me when I'll
be driving ticking doing long drives I'm
using the GPS Nick cover the directions
I might be making sure you guys have
phones all right so again what I wanted
to do king is on worst case scenarios
cuz obviously you know we got a lot out
- shout - boom - boom you were there
with us
Oh Eddie yes it's like um you know one
of the complaints that we got was like
well you guys were in a controlled
environment where Microsoft had X cloud
you were connected wired or wirelessly
home for every every situation you know
us was wireless so we were farm and I'm
saying what a lot of people like I need
to see real world so all these tests
that I did with this is off a 4G
cellular network no modify cuz my setup
at the crib is strong and I'm saying
5g you know all that why five files on
up I'm out here I didn't want to do that
because I want to assimilate the common
Joe first off I threw up out of the four
games you got halo you got gears you
guys see it thieves you got killer
instinct doing no first alright so the
first off takes about 30 to 40 seconds
just to boot in to get the stream to
come down so once you get going you can
rock out you literally halo like you are
on your dashboard can't do the campaign
first super solid once I got my bearings
just getting used to the screen moving
around
everything was butter had no problems
now the next was on halo halo online
that's the big test
since the FPS you fighting against
people first thing off the back or front
I did notice a little latency on the
left analog sometime so it's kind of
throwing me off a little bit I'm gonna
ignore me off the other thing I would
say was that um oh shout out that I'm
wild trash and he'll if I want that play
like these dudes are Here I am right
like I thought it was gonna go that it
was not going down you can't play
campaign you just go and play multiply
but you can play it's literally the full
copy of the game oh yeah so you could do
whatever
you want so I would never know about the
left stick yeah like like I don't play
it but then it I just felt my a little
slight was it to the point where it's
unplayable
no yeah but I will say like it was
noticeable enough that I felt like I
couldn't get busy the way I wanted to
get busy right but then on the second
playthrough some say let me just tweak
my analog sensitivity cuz you know I
hate him tweet cuz I think it did for
his like three so I moved it up to like
four or five now once I did that Oh your
boy was in the building
it will I was moving I was shaking I was
posted to the side gone clip all that
everything was going that it was crispy
class thank you yeah I don't know who's
move no that it but I'm classic heimo
you know I'm saying it was definitely
seamless maybe no screen Tara baby like
a resolution dropped maybe once every
three or four matches but like five
seconds and boom it'll come right back
to pristine condition so halo wow like I
was again cellular network y'all I'm not
on Wi-Fi which is the optimal you know
I'm saying right but this is me 4G so
next up was gears yo Pratt man this is
the showcase gears it is to show guy
what's your question get knows you say
is it is it like was it like 101 on
gears because I mean and did it have you
know did you see a lot of high texture
it no let me explain something you've
got glad you asked that we all know
gears is the graphical showcase for them
are PC it's a different Explorer PC we
already know I'm saying yeah it's one
day race I hate like I'm not gonna front
that is the game to showcase X cloud not
only again yes nine you know I got for
this out 4k HDR so seeing that game with
that clarity on phone was amazing and
then whatever reason the response time
felt better in Gears that it did in halo
that just touches me that gears felt
one-to-one on cellular I did all three
modes I did hey I did
the newer game yeah I was just a big old
you know you could be the lady
I could be they may know they take her
in already
I did I did horde I did multiplayer the
like I said the only nitpick I gotta say
about gears was that the HDR is so good
that when you go and you playing
campaign are you playing anything in a
dark area it's really dark on your phone
so you got to turn the brightness up you
know saying that's the only thing I like
you only like you watch HD all you see
the Sun there's Sun like the Rays
everything nice but then you go to a
dark area and then you kind of see more
of the disparity it's very more
prominent on phone so they gotta have to
let you tweak around with that a little
bit but um yeah man like it was super
impressive I can't front you're like
doing all those molds it was sorcery uh
you know you move the analog around and
see the camera just go like this and one
to one I'm sorry about the fighting game
you know
there we go let's get to it full
disclosure I hate killing like that
fighting this should be happening on the
Lord's Day saying it's never been a
thing for me personally you know I'm
saying so you know I just messing around
with that I was like my whole thing is I
just want to see inputs cuz we know
we're fighting games you need that
directional pad you did be able to block
and I'm saying like all that is super so
the fact that it even got killer
instinct on this to me that's Microsoft
what they chest out right because you
really not support like I've done PS now
in a stream and you can't do fine games
with that man right it's not a go and
I'm going for it I did got some old coal
um I think it's like um something shadow
mode there's some new mode yeah and it's
like in Judas or EOC you know what I'm
talking about right yeah and yeah that
was kind of to tour just get the feeling
oh one to one blocking doing my little
ultra combo and all that stuff and
precise inputs timing the blocking was
that low-key probably is probably the
most impressive based on the type of
game it is even more so in a sense of
gears is the graphical show point case
halo is third person I mean have a
first-person gears third-person this is
the fighting these are three hard genre
and all them sixty frames I believe
collision sixty but um yeah that you
know real quick these are games that
when you talk about like you know input
latency and 101 these are the kind of
games where you really need to have that
you can't afford to have any kind of
latency seroff to hear you talk about
almost that one-to-one experience over a
4G LTE network just imagine this is
invaded imagine one 5g hits that's what
I'm saying it's gonna be but it's gonna
be really special because again this is
4G now I'm moving around the house and
also remember there's another additional
latency factor in the fact that remember
I am so most people recommend just going
tether from controller to your to your
output dry here right I'm technically
adding Bluetooth is an extra a slight
extra layer of Layton yes right so
technically still not the most optimal
ping and I'm still getting one to one
that's why I wanted to try it this way
because this to me is the average Joe
this to me is the kid you know I'm
saying that's gonna play that has its
fortnight or whatever whatever that's
gonna play in that manner and I'm not
gonna live man like it's sorcery to me I
still don't know how they do it like I'm
just like this is question for you
cutting you know go for them um when
you're doing the S Club are you actually
is it is it your account that's attached
to this game right like so when you stop
playing right yes and you go on your
xbox are you continuing we honestly it's
literally as if you're logging into
another Xbox so no it's move I found out
all the dudes that are doing this and
I'm not gonna blast y'all out here but I
know who's doing it because I could tell
when you're log in you log back out your
log in your lower back and I seen COG
doing it then I seen somebody else doing
it and I seen somebody else doing it and
I know
I'm moving upset that y'all are doing it
though what asset come question a lot of
people says remote streaming listen I
got remote play streaming I have both
and Christopher Hart and I'm gonna tell
you right now it's not even close
it's it's impressive what remote cloud
streaming is doing it for I mean we're
gonna play kind of things doing for
PlayStation don't get me wrong it is
it's not the one-to-one like you can
tell basically when I was playing
destiny and all that stuff
I was compensating on PlayStation for
the lag when I was playing X cloud it
got to the point you know when you just
forget that you're even doing something
like you you get your mind clicks in
muscle memory because it's it's the same
exact feeling so I'm trying not to get
busy now you say now wait no to get big
because now I'm not even thinking that
I'm playing on it feels one-to-one so
that was that shouts Ecco need yours my
man salut the legend he said what a
newer smartphone make a difference from
your ass not possibly I'm saying like
that that's definitely issue I know they
had some issues with Bluetooth thinking
so so that was a joint I went and saw
that galaxy is telling how much it costs
for that there one terabit Mesa 1600
yeah that went directly into the bushes
guy did have a slight sync issue with
gears father couldn't get my latest save
data so I was towards getting the latest
cloud save it confined yeah I didn't
have that issue but I know what you're
saying and in reference to kids point
the fact that it's your account you know
I'm saying that you're just logging into
it put on yeah that was dad the last
we'll see it thieves and to me that's
just a graphical showcase cuz you know
game does look beautiful
you know HD ah so you got the slave
dancer I remember one of my first gay
peaks braces I'll see if these was with
you King yes and you were dancing it we
sat there got drunk and dance mix it
afire for least a half an hour to know
before we even got to so what do you
guys are saying king is you're part of
those millions playing yeah yes I'm part
of the million and brat was down with me
as far as the millions and millions of
people and better play and see if these
at this very moment stitch I don't know
when it's coming to us we'll find out
but oh now I'll say about see if these
again there was it really wasn't that
much to test
I was that point with the other three
games kind of blow me away I was already
in the know like this is gonna be fine
like I'm not even worried about it but I
will say I just need to know cuz you
think they have the X but you don't
press the Xbox Live button and then you
get your guy they have like a miniature
version of the guide it doesn't have the
full functionality you can see your
friends but I want and you can invite to
party but I want to know how they handle
that like cuz like do right now or okay
you do party bro
Xbox Live function now let me tell you
something halo I'm playing Halo and some
thirteen year old
trihard is talking crap and I'm hearing
it do it like gay out here busting me up
oh this is power I could even get mad I
was like yo this is fire like I'm
getting voice of the dashboard and
everything bro full - boy that's it's
like that on PC - too ridiculous bro I'm
telling y'all right now full Xbox Live
function is my guess is we know they got
the Xbox Live app so maybe they use that
in just want to know how am I supposed
to put my headset connected to my phone
I want to know how to handle they
definitely have that it's going to
happen it's just a matter of how they
implemented you know I'm saying but yo
full Xbox Live guy yeah it was I mean it
would make sense if they wanted to maybe
make some sort of a wireless headset
that you could get to use exclusively
with you know I mean my question is did
you try with your bluetooth earpiece
joint to connect because member when my
phone I've got a Bluetooth headset
I've got a GoPro I've got other
Bluetooth devices that syncs to this I
had to literally turn everything off of
those other ones and I'm just to get
this to sing so I don't think they want
the additional wireless mic bluetooth
kind of interfering with that's my
that's my guess but it that will be - I
think they're gonna go traditional where
you literally plug in to your you know
I'm saying to your output right because
you know what
The Listening the astros worked I shall
put the Astros directly in and they work
but I didn't mic functionality so I just
want to see how they handle it okay
yeah Cognito I was gonna say uh but even
but the the newer phones that are coming
out now aren't gonna have that headset
jack so they got to figure out how to
address that issue yes that's why I'm
say that is the question because clearly
they're pushing at the Xbox Live app the
guide and porn chat they are pushing it
so they must have either part of a
package or something that they're gonna
they're gonna have to come up with an
accessory even the click thing this is
probably about like 10 bucks I got this
from Amazon you know I'm saying but um
they're gonna have to come up with
almost like an X cloud start a kid you
know saying like here's the clip here's
the you know I'm saying a microphone it
should be sold when a deluxe package
with all elite tools yes give me the
fact that elite - now you gotta have the
battery lithium attached into my crap I
don't like that I will say this it's a
conclusion you know I'm saying like I
said all the games I said the only
negative I would say is most of these
developers we know that the API you know
these guys are gonna work with these
guys with the new SDKs and stuff to make
games project X file ready because
you're gonna have to get your phones up
you know nobody's fonts are small on
phone when you're trying to you don't
look at certain things and your menus
and stuff like that a cog and they
actually have something called cloud
where that they're releasing the
developers that's gonna address that
yeah bogus he took my cube ara
he took my he's he's he's ela he's like
the Lakers he's signing people no he's
not like the Laker got LeBron over there
cuz you don't he's more like the Bucs so
your bucks go right to the bushes and
until you show me your receipt saying
that you got your stadia on the waist
I would like to you to refrain and pull
that man loose because he is bogus like
it's day via pre-order ready to kick you
guys out the value bar we do not know
you know you're not slender might want
to go over there you know listen like
right in this place I might should be
over here on this team but if Mike if
the bag is drop I'm not gonna tell the
man don't take a [ __ ] how much are you go
over there and fix up these stuff
because they might need help so bogus he
eats all the help he can get in
conclusion like I said I do feel they
coming y'all this is the first time
because I'm like to be real I'm trying
to break it I will try to break it ain't
got my connection the average you're
gonna be outside with his phone on 4G
and that's what its gonna be in is this
going hang and the [ __ ] did you go to
the bodega with it will you I took this
thing over to do world look at you talk
about the people faces because right now
if they if they if they package it right
they we know we still in beta I'm gonna
tell you right in a switch game y'all
know y'all know I've been coming hard
for a long time if Microsoft can pull
this off I'm telling y'all right because
I can see kids doing this I could see it
I could literally see it yo please read
that that's for you to read no no no
that black brat we just wrap is stepped
away buster be okay king with Phil
Harrison is the soldier boy version
but I think you own the Sun like no
people beyond the stuff but I really
think you want the boss we'll go be the
jib with his ex our facts that's gonna
go down you know saying go between sets
fam there's a shot the Delilah HD she
said I love it I've been fortunate to
test a project internally for months
that's all thank you for saying I know
the light won't blow you up cuz I know
you in the know and I just want to say
shout out to the team cuz ya'll got out
here killing it and um wow I didn't
expect you okay do you think you think
that should that Microsoft should market
another device kind of like the switch
goodbye you know what I was looking at
people play on their mobile phone like
the functionality wasn't really
something that I would do it's fine if
you would like I could see myself
playing this on like my TV a tablet like
a nice decent sized screen tablet not
necessarily myself X cloud has the
mobile is much is we don't like it right
we want to play a non-traditional screen
but these kids are on their phones these
kids are doing it so I will agree with
you on this wave wrap I would like if X
cloud comes out with that option where
you are now doing it in your browser
which I'm pretty confident they are
working on then they really throw steady
in the bushes because that's what stadia
is doing right stadia is like yo we're
not giving you mobile unless it's this
specific phone right right Mika's you're
saying we're doing all of Android right
and then eventually we're doing all of
that's more users right so my thing is I
can see again this is my theory I could
be wrong I just seen more people more
kids then you look at the SK SK Telecom
deal but they did right when Korea yep
yes not only browsers they are literally
on their phones they're on this so if
this they give you that access at that
point of entry do you and lift the tech
if people see the tech the way I play
detective if that experience remains the
same or improves this is gonna blow
people
it's notice that extreme well at exhale
you got a question I heard you I was
just saying that um you know what do you
think if they made it a dedicated device
they used X plane yeah I'd really I'd
rather it sound like you and a berry
going over Niagara Falls
I agree I grew a breath I think we do
know there were prototype devices
shouted just quoting from our window
central um that we do know they were
prototype devices the day of work at or
so there's a possibility of cooking up a
dedicated device which that form factor
but some people like rap there's gonna
be people like breath that do want that
don't want to use their fullness or the
thing is is you know it'd be easier cuz
you're gonna get those people that play
on phones regardless because that's what
they do but if you made a dedicated
device you know that relied on the
internet you know they they would have a
lot better chance to get the people that
don't want to play on they phones cuz
right
the biggest thing is like I don't want
to play on my phone I don't really I
don't care by next cloud but if you gave
me a device that had a built-in
controller right and you know especially
if you know they had a lot of technology
going into you know the Wi-Fi and stuff
that's in it already built into that
controller you have a lot better chance
of doing stuff because I have no
interest in X cloud whatsoever oh yeah
let's get okay so we got a $5 to chat
from us it's not what Microsoft pulled
this off it's when the competition are
going to try stadia is dead on arrival
though Dominus Maximus that's right so
remember liaison now are we on the car
is that the current name for fulfill
these days yes it really is yet you know
he will only obtain Aurelius by
ascending so yes and he has to really
come with the slow-mo backslap and take
out you know the other competition he's
gotta ascend into greatness before you
know right now what he did was he fought
really hard to get to where we at right
of this Phil thing going on man but you
hear kognito talking about X cloud right
now that wasn't possible a minute ago
like a minute ago that wasn't a thought
and you know he's changing minds he's
shaken we've been around the block we've
known the smoke and mirrors we know no
event and they show you best-case
scenario scope I'm just carrying real
quick hmm what is Phil Spencer's next
name because I don't know there really
is his name will be if he could pull
this off which will be the greatest
trick ever
all right this will be the greatest
trick ever they're coming to the next
generation kicking in chesses and all
this other stuff and doing it with a
smile we're also not hurting the
competition like well I got talked on
boom breakfast with boom if if like this
thing is packaged in a fashion that you
get it with the game pass and xbox live
ultimate rolled into one right so this
is added in then let's say this is this
happens right and date and date you know
you get first party games inside man you
pass now you sell the ghost system let's
say your system is 500 499 and you know
you get your controller and then you
have the little game pass thing to free
two months or three months or a month of
game pass that mean initially you do not
have to purchase halo you don't have to
purchase any of the first party games
that will be coming out and you have a
backlog of 200 games it's inside not not
saying that you know back that back
impact is not their back and Pat is
there from day one
then you bundled out with the cloud that
frees up a whole bunch of cash for you
to buy your PlayStation 5 or your switch
bro so he is trying to conquer the game
while still elevating the other guys and
not taken away is I look at it like it's
a win-win for everybody and there's one
thing I forgot to mention remember I'm
testing project cloud streaming that
into the cloud they also have
from your console you know you didn't do
that after that function is not
available yet that's not this is all
from the cloud which to me is even quite
crazy impressive right so imagine now
you're in a situation where you don't
you're not next to just read graphically
you're not next to one of their servers
I know Charlotte just going again I
believe he's in Germany or something
like that and I think right now
cloud X cloud the the initial of test
beta is only in UK and United States and
obviously or Korea so in his situation
right now the azure servers in our next
to him so he would experience maybe he
would experience more latency but if he
had if the console streaming is set up
then your server your Xbox access server
to to you almost a remote into that and
then from my understanding it's all your
games not just the ones that's limited
to 2 X cloud so ok yeah
this question this question that I'm
having so the fact that they was putting
the azure cloud system together and they
were putting what was they putting in
three sixties or Xbox ones in there good
point
this is the Xbox one as tech this is not
even the scarlet jacket that's the other
part that's crazy
you remember that the what's in the
server blades right now or Xbox one SS
that is great this is that even so again
once the infrastructure upgrades and
then they're ready to roll out come
scarlet and that's finalized we still
have not seen the best of this to shout
out to the the tech that came up with
that that ingenious idea let's have the
server's have these in because you know
probably as clownin we do that yeah the
fact that it makes complete sense that
that's what's powering your device right
those are the game that you're gonna be
playing so why not have the tech mirror
the actual you know blades that's inside
that is ingenious that's one of the ways
they are able to conquer the latency
issue somehow on the back end we gotta
get we got to get the laws of cloud
on the IOP again but um you know we
definitely they have some type of
technical sorcery right now that even
I'm blown away and I will say this I
will reveal this that you know shout the
love they'll stay with that he did tell
us that he three is that um you know one
thing that surprised me was online
multi-player right cuz you've it
mentally you figure that's the harder
thing how you know because you may be
it's like you going you know to the
cloud then you go on from the cloud and
while and he's like no he's like god
that's the route from the online I guess
you know server server base to the cloud
so that part blew me away and to play
these games to play Halo 60 frames per
second and like I said at minor I make
it a slight resolution drop in five ten
seconds and come back and I'm still but
by all doing this the control is tight
yes I had the more my sensitivity up on
Halo but on Gears one to one bro horde
mode multiplayer campaign yo I cannot
and this is a beta okay let's keep it
true right like this is that even you're
not even nigut now granted my
experiences maybe my experience and
other people may say na kar I played it
and I was in the bushes and I ain't got
you know my cell phone tower situation
ain't what it is hey I can only speak
for me and I'm saying like the joint was
crazy shout out the game about choice
for our super chat this X cloud tech
sounds awesome great show guys
I'm impressed I'm impressed I gotta say
I'm more jealous
I was super gassed up listen let me tell
you guys listen I got the email writing
so some equipment in the chat he said uh
yellow did anybody get accepted I was
doing with you yeah 2x clouds I'm like I
didn't check man I was rubbing the dirt
off my man so I checked my email boy my
whole head blew up right because it's a
X cloud
something t-mobile boom verify your
account oh my god
so I jumped inside I was like yeah I'm a
verified can i screenshot it
hey y'all bad right and I send it to the
class I said what like this
Yeah right yes t-mobile users y'all
getting the fast track to this thing
there exactly
Musti then I saw something pop up on
Twitter yes
something popped up on Twitter and I say
well normally I just don't look inside
certain mail I'm like people he added me
to dumb things so I win and then I
looked and I just sucked my teeth
because I already knew it was over for
me by the time I got to quick shout-out
to cheese I'll be shout-out to school
Terry chief he said I've been playing a
game that's on the cloud and it's wack
it's not even streaming like y'all be
talking about I'm not sold on a basic
Kyle all right first off chief did you
play a cloud need to know that that's
number one because number two if it's
not s cloud then we can't have this
discussion number three no disrespect um
as far as school talk how can you know
how much data did burn I'm all for G I
got a limited data y'all so that could
be a problem for those who run around
you know on a cell phone bill that ain't
that a premium I don't know what a
situation my situation on my 4G I got
frozen LTE in 4G
I got unlimited data unlimited text that
whole thing so it was a non-issue for me
but I will say this shout out the boss
move battery life could be at issue
y'all because what's going on yeah yeah
I was out I was I was out for about like
maybe 3 hours start out 100% battery I
probably rock down to about 30 something
already I had to charge up this is this
is dominating your phone like there's no
running around it I almost have to treat
it like to switch when we used to take
the raft power or power bricks King
nobody to take a little bricks you don't
have to have your poverty you know
saying and also we got to think about
for the controller game how you guys um
what you call it you know handle that if
your controller die you know I'm saying
like how do is gonna rock with that as
well so I know I'm about to buy a note
cuz I'm gonna need a big screen no it's
the basic cloud no stream listen man I
can't speak for yo experience brother I
just telling you what I experienced it
was
that's all I got but yeah that's alright
I just wanna say this is this is
fascinating here this man I mean I
always thought Microsoft's always been
kind of ahead of the puck with where
things are going in gaming from a
technological standpoint they did with
Xbox Live 17 years ago and they included
the Ethernet port and the internal hard
drive on the console you know and I
think if they can get this thing working
on you know TVs computers and you're
telling me that I just need to pay you
know whatever it is for game pass and I
can play all these games this is a huge
advantage if I'm looking at stadia from
a value perspective this is a huge huge
advantage for them I remember Brett I
always told you before when I was so
high on anthem y'all was over the moon
sort of jet boots flying out of you you
guys were going nuts and I said listen I
don't see the market for that at all I
didn't see with fit and with the stadia
stuff again I don't see where it fits
and I'm not just saying it from a
standpoint of me there's millions of
people out here and I always like to use
that word millions right these millions
of people are here that don't get it
like they don't get the fact that are
these same millions plane CDs yeah those
are the millions of people they looking
at do we have like the same millions
doing everything okay so these millions
they don't understand that first of all
they don't to explain the tech to
certain people it does not even work
they got to have it in their hand right
but then you tell these people you're
gonna have to purchase a full price game
and don't have anything to show for it
and you don't really have confidence
inside this company because this company
has
showing you they can pick something up
and then if it don't work right within a
couple of months I'll get this all yay
am i for money I gotta read this so we
have Tim from Lodz
I'm selling my Xbox one that's an PC 4x
cloud now you're on he's not selling his
piece he's pcmasterrace for life but he
said please don't be like these dudes
that's always out here proclaiming it
getting rid of one system for the next
for no reason nobody cares should be the
new shirt listen guys we have a hundred
and three hundred and five people in
here let's get those likes up
we have great guests on this show these
guys woke up very early in the morning
you got boom up you gotta breath up you
got kids smooth Oh buddy NEMA turn the
green screen on wait till he gets
shorter moons in you're not gonna be
able to I think connects your remote
wirelessly or something like that
okay 60 Wow
no but you know you think with Google I
think they're selling point is is you
know you tear down that barrier no
that's what that's what it's for though
I mean it's Ito there that's the selling
point like you don't have to borrow
hardware to you know your $500 console
or
$2,000 PC you can just gonna be buying
all those millions of games that that's
already out
yeah the library yeah if you have a game
on xbox it's already Project X
cloud-enabled in some form right yeah
they'll be streaming or whether it be
you know right the classroom or whether
become so streaming so that the proud to
sell that they're gonna probably gonna
have is now you're telling me I gotta go
by destiny again you're saying to get
more version of destiny that's Linux
based that Deb's got a developed for
literally what we were told
it's a flick of a switch it's already
big right the developers actually have
to work on the stadia side to get it to
work yeah that that's the day if you got
to see you don't you know King when King
says he's onto something get ready
should be usually everyone should be
taking notes
man that was twelve my grandfather now
you know you people are in there Chad
you don't know where father we we missed
the lead toward us the ways of the force
of wheelin and dealin and i'ma tell you
this right now if you look at what
Microsoft and i'ma say correctly Phil
Dominus Maximus Spencer 14x King do we
condone that you will stop your
pettiness right now you'd agree with him
right now I mean the thing is this you
have to look at it first of all right
they won't they have been real careful
about saying how we're gonna pay for
this service right and everyone and I
think it's safe to assume right without
making an a out of anybody right is that
this is gonna be baked into ultimate
game pass it makes sense right they're
not gonna have a separate charge
Microsoft isn't it
torian's putting these deal together yes
and being the most consumer friendly
company right and developer and gaming
and gaming entity right they want to
make sure that their customers feel like
they're getting the maximum dollar
amount for what they are pushing right
so when this grunge when the beta is
done in this becomes a full thing if you
are an ultimate game payer subscriber
think about what you're getting right
besides two hundred plus games that are
there that are changing monthly and it
used to be just one time a month where
you were getting games now they've
gotten really froggy right there's two
and three times a month when new games
are going in one in the beginning one in
the middle and one towards the end and
then of course within we're starting
this two cycle over again getting people
excited big titles little titles right
you're getting first party game you're
getting first party games in their day
and date and they're staying there right
unlike only service where they're
pulling got a warrant to you in two
months right
right all first party games staying in
there you're gonna you're gonna get the
ability to play these games on the go
wherever you want whenever you want all
for the price of $15 a month and if you
are a frugal person like the king and
myself I'm paid up until 2022 because I
jumped on all the good we are what here
we enter in 2019 so for the next three
years the king and I want I love it yeah
you got it so I'm there all day or Phil
shout-out to cult shout out to cope for
going in on you dues yelling out that
dollar stuff
shout out because because when he put
that tweet out I laughed so down so many
PS he came with the hardcore facts I
think that people people always forget
that like you know Netflix who like they
all give the first month for free
your shout out to Texas Lisa they charge
extra for exercise no go for me that the
vibe we're hearing right now and what a
blow was alluding to is game pass
ultimate will be the way that's the way
that that's what they want you at
if you're looking at it right and let's
be real okay wouldn't you all if you a
console maker right now wouldn't want to
just shut down that whole console making
and making sure that you can get a
service or app on something's the best
trick in the world is to sell somebody
nothing right nothing to have them pay
for something that all you had to do was
just have a couple of dudes sitting the
woman put together a program and they
can farm that program out to any device
in the world and you don't have to
physically get up in order to store and
purchase anything the moment you go to
you're placed on you hit install and you
can play from the RIP right there that
that's so powerful did your Mac that's
how Amazon and these dudes got so huge
by hitting that yes I want that
delivered today let me get Prime yeah so
free shipping notice that you know Prime
doesn't make other subscription services
they just keep making more value in the
one they currently have yes so you gotta
understand yeah I'm gonna get all
everybody wants to get out of the the
hard way of making business it's
probably stuff for Nintendo um because
Nintendo on the show sell your new
joystick or how to play something every
once in a while you know because they
are innovators they're actually the
obvious starting to be lured X cloud
company hi listen it's I can't I can't
understate this thing man it is really
rather him be palm palming this and then
switch it yeah I like that
mix switches new bushes for cocky you
know I'm just glad that he said it from
his mouth and they get it right or they
do whatever they gonna do he's gonna
throw it in the bushes and I'm gonna
record it into the bushes and we're
gonna we're gonna make a meme out of it
so y'all can put in a chat and you have
to show to me by the bush and him
throwing it in the woods
no sob gonna be bad or betrayed of but
it's just it's something to be said to
have in these triple-a experiences this
is if you can get over the best little
kid we know how we feel about our
achievements you know how we feel about
the Xbox Live infrastructure it's just
it's home answers like I am so happy we
broke them up you know I caused some
missing the day starting submissive or
receive millions of people millions go
sad the rapist if Phil is loving I Lord
yes right I will say this there is
something to be said like you said like
to having those triplet experiences on a
mobile device but I think not just that
having access to your content outside of
having access to it just only on the
Xbox console and you know I'm
experiencing now now on my PC and I'm
telling you like it's just it's nice
it's the reason why I bought a PC
because I still had access to that no
system yes so you're playing um Xbox
stuff on your PC I'm playing it well I'm
playing destiny to you right now my
piece no but I was playing here's 5 on
PC with wujin you know an import a it
was oh my god oh that was crazy that's
crazy who did definitely listen listen
green I need a sauce is deep it wasn't
so bogus was it actually was part of the
Xbox team
he was many years ago was he was and we
had to remove him
he's a man with no country running
that's what I got bad check it out you
guys if anybody is able to get into the
excavator there so please please post
your experiences let me know what you
guys think again it's just one man's
opinion
just to let y'all know but what I
experienced but that's what I got Lord
King is going on with the outer world oh
well I thought using preface it cuz
usually you like him yeah
so basically you know we it's our worlds
been in the news this week lot going on
so well first of all let's shout out our
brother ISM of the xbox two ran out Thor
and the chase Gordon of Windows central
because it was hot and heavy in these
Twitter streets breath did you see it
was good yeah yeah yeah our world came
out and I guess the initial report was
that the Xbox one X would only have
enhancements on 4k that whole bit the
treatment but was told that told to them
that um initially that a PlayStation 4
with that pro will not have any
enhancements so that said Twitter on
fire the interwebs
were at war this is unfair how are they
Microsoft the evil Microsoft making this
first party game studios [ __ ] the
PlayStation version yes it was it was
hot Navi and people were calling foul
they were throwing flags on the field
King so then you know the news came out
and it looks child to Jeff Gordon he he
had the email from the PR team who told
him him specifically what had happened
cuz people are attacking like how could
you you know post a story whatever
you're saying he lied and she yeah I'm
so ridiculous yeah Brandon jazz for
holding it down providing the evidence
that they got this straight for the PR
team they were not running with a story
and it was eventually debunked by
private division so Lord King where we
at with all this outer world stuff well
this is power yeah it's only 25th that
comes out
yes yes yes yes so this must anticipate
a game that's about to hit these streets
and it looks phenomenal
if you've seen all the marketing that
Microsoft is putting behind this game
it's in game past day and day isn't it
guys
yes yes so you have an OPC - yes if you
happen to have that you'll definitely be
playing that for the you know for the
low low cost of what they say $1 or
whatever and it is also being released
on the PlayStation 4 what is that 59 so
what we're gonna do here we're gonna do
it just like this we're gonna move it
just like this right so you can actually
purchase the game on Microsoft for the
same 59.95 with enhancements if you have
an Xbox one X you can have the 4k
hopefully it's 30 uh maybe it might be
60 I don't know but when I get into my
house I know it's gonna be for Kate
native and I know that see everybody
wants the PlayStation to do something
that it can't do it cannot do native 4k
and if it does it's probably like one of
those little indie game that you really
don't care about but when you can really
want to get serious and down to the
mustard and get down to the the grind of
it Phil wanted that power in our it is
for this exact reason right there how
would you sell this premium edition of
our awards to the millions of people
that want to play what millions
I said listen man you know and I will
come up and I would I would have a heavy
heart as I grab the microphone out of
world's would be coming out of the 25th
October on all major platforms there's
one platform that you can get a premium
experience for just one dollar if you
just joined game paths like one of those
commercials trying to be chattered you
to you to for just $1 you can get out of
worlds and 200 other game
play or or you can go down the road and
get the inferior version for 59.95 for
one singular game and and you can
experience that one game with a high
price of fifty nine ninety five how
would you feel king knowing that if
you're on PlayStation you don't have
access to to game pass for the dollar
the body xbox just for one game CC attic
and this is where I'm gonna blow your
mind I'm gonna put the Firecracker in
your ear and blow your mind maybe I'll
check it out this is the m80 boom this
is the blow your brains pause come check
out when you buy an xbox and you get
game pass you don't just get how the
world's brother-brother do you want to
say what you get award winning games
award winning games you get there's the
wharf you know you got a deal oh brother
where are you as you can father the ward
winning Forza I mean listen I'm saying
this is where Xbox is hitting its stride
and game pass is the vehicle is the
juice it's pushing it forward
PlayStation may not need a game pass you
know why because all y'all hundred and
twenty-five or a hundred and fifty
million people got it you got nothing to
show for it right now and I listen I
would love honestly I'm not gonna lie
honestly I I hope that they start to
lose so bad that they really change
around the structuring of PlayStation
now now for nothing to be honest with
you this is this is what I'm talking
about here you have the game that's
coming out and not just because
microsoft owns the game company and and
that game was already in development so
that's why it's coming out on
playstation and you're gonna honor that
contract but you don't have to give it
to y'all guys for free so it's gonna be
on this place for free but if
PlayStation now was in the same position
that game ass is right now how cool
would that be that the game is being
released date and date to you guys as
well and we can use these services I
want every system that we have to have a
service function like this so that you
don't buy no I'm not buying enough of
Xbox game at all
all right I'm keeping it funky with you
guys that's not what do you feel about
this whole world statement I don't care
I'm gonna preload that on my xbox
through game pass mm-hmm and plate with
the millions of people got to play
through game fans mmm but what about
what about the whole admission thing
with remember they said but but people
thought there was a disparity when
people thought that Microsoft was
playing tourney there's still a
disparity well truth for it as far as
performance yes we know the X is a
superior version yes but but to the
point as if they weren't gonna be any
playstation enhancements when we
initially thought like where you at with
that attic like do you think that would
have been crazy out of bounds or hey it
is what it is look man
Sony be doing way more suspect yeah go
for it man go for it go for it first off
we even act like Call of Duty don't have
an exclusive mode for a year do you feel
like you need to make that first off
once 1440p what's 4k is is that how it
goes like yeah I don't keep track of
this stuff I just turned the game on a
plate but you know if that's how it is
like it's not my fault Sony didn't do
that they didn't buy the studio so they
don't read the right to tell them what
to do with theirs their game mm-hmm well
maybe a Saudi spent more money than just
buying them Sonic they have 4k on their
console
did I eat Jeff of Italy that would just
give um yeah I don't the body was
trippin cuz all I heard when the ex came
out a power doesn't matter where's the
game so they shouldn't be caring about
this supposed at 1080p game so like I
think they have that energy over a
resolution versus having that energy
over destiny like there's there's Xbox
people let's don't got some destiny
content from destiny one and now we call
a duty it's like no don't don't even say
anything just keep quiet and if you want
to be really real um the outer Wars is
published by who
private division really Microsoft really
didn't have really that's that was up to
a private day division and the Obsidian
to really do that and you know I noticed
that there's like some miscommunication
with the whole is Pro getting enhance
stuff like like I'm just sitting you're
like why are we what's wrong with this
we are going at everyone else knowing a
man but the people who gave the
information okay I'm just like man lay
it and you know part of me feels like
the only reason this happens is because
you know it you know obviously you know
the whole thing to happen with with
Windows central and you know they got
the PR thing and you know they literally
were just going off information that the
are told you got a super you know so we
got a we got a $5 tip chat from a stitch
669 in the past games so uh so causes
this coming generation I think services
will sell consoles mmm you know what you
might be on it you know when when Xbox a
PlayStation go up there on the front
lines you know next holiday to try to
poach the millions of people know this
potion is billions we've got millions
already I just feel like I really do you
know you know we won't go into the whole
thing but I really feel like if this
wouldn't have been like if they wouldn't
have bought this game this student you
know this won't even be an issue like
this happens all the time and it's never
but now all since since Microsoft owes
the company now Microsoft's doing this
you know I just I get so tired of
because I'm like what my dad what
happened with red day right like comes
out that it runs that looks better on
the eggs I mean have an X I don't care
like but it's just like pink I get this
man and eggs he's gonna get this scarlet
we don't we we bypassing man he already
in the know but my question addict are
you trying to say that PlayStation
people are happy when it's in their
favor but when it's not it's really foul
oh no you can't mean that you know I
didn't want to use the B word but
someone had to say Apple of both sides
but you know the allow the up word came
because game before did a deep dive on
this game back in March and and the
actual developer did say that the
console versions were gonna be
experiencing 4k so that's where a lot of
the most of the diffusion they get some
kind of like quote from a developer or
something no they interviewed the
developer Game Informer did a deep dive
the developer they sat down with the
developer and developer said yeah the
game's gonna be for Kayla on all
consoles Brad connections look B G yeah
all I'm saying is right now because gate
pass you don't let's be real Microsoft a
making them hot games but let you know
theoretically if you know they start
launching those really nice games and
Xbox got 85 plus games on game pads and
we're not gonna act like Sony Cosell
calls so Sonny's gonna sell consoles but
people are buying Xbox is for game pads
like they really are my high school
teacher my high school teacher bought an
Xbox ain't own an Xbox and probably 10
years he but would because the game
passed because I think of the day what
you do is you set yourself up to be the
perfect side console if you're not most
of these people that are gonna buy this
car
box is a side chick these people were
not going to buy an Xbox in the first
place but when you give them the option
like look like you only want to Xbox for
the Halos for the gears the games that
we play that you do enjoy
we got something called game path you
just give us $10 a month then you got it
any what Matt Smith sells out the mess
he said the only thing I use on my xbox
is game path look I get it
some people don't like services some
people hate the services you know but at
the end of the day people are buying
console free service like it's just how
it is
guys it might not be the best thing for
you you know some people like physically
owning this though I still saw someone
the other day in a podcast I rewrote
podcaster they says it is all these
people won't buy an xbox cape but don't
do the service services are convenient
for you because you want to be cheap but
they're not convenient for people that
want to be chief just you got your
question like you remember that old car
are you go remember you go yes yes I
wrapped death traps right and you know
you go couldn't go past 60 miles an hour
right remember that yeah because that
was the limit so you trying to get that
controller you go to go 100 miles an
hour and it can't do a baby you can't do
four just deal with the facts no what
I'm saying is that this goes back not to
4k but to the fact that the game is
gonna have any answers that's what
that's why a lot of people were kind of
like well wait a minute I'm 1080p to
1440p well that does I'm saying it is an
enhancement but they were saying no
enhancement so people were saying we'll
wait a minute like you know you gave me
for my article where the developer was
talking about this game they did confirm
enhancements oh oh I think that's an
enhancement from 1080p to 1440p that's
an enhancement
and you guys should be proud of that you
should beat your chest you should be
really happy that you got 1440p oh look
Brad let me get you get to get you on
this um
when then use initially came out and
yeah we were told there was a disparity
that the pro would not get any
enhancements King you know go ahead and
click his picture down there
because I know you could do you could
show everyone just king when you've read
that when you read that distinctly what
was the look on your face when you first
read that sentence that probably is not
gonna get any enhancements at all just
like this I ready to sit like the
Cheshire Cat and I was the Cheshire Cat
just sat up in trees and was like it has
begun no I don't think any of this that
was done for publicity just to get like
because they waited before they
clarified they wanted to get everybody
talking like I feel like the point you
remember what you remember with that
plagiarizing thing did four dead cells
nobody was checking for Eggman money
Eagle good afternoon
doors there over one thousand quality
exclusive games on xbox new games
released every day for your information
the best game subjectively are not
triple-a add up the filly Eagle I think
you are onto something mom and there are
millions of people of continue all kid
oh no I just feel like um the timing and
how long they waited before they
clarified AI think it was done for
publicity they took advantage of that
they knew it will be something that
would catch traction is good for the
game especially like with and when the
Martin believe I know King mentioned
something about the marketing I don't
feel the marketing has been that strong
for
I know I've seen it but like there's
been a lot of major stuff from like
obsidian and whatnot I think I still it
still doesn't giving me that like that
let's say that Fallout vibe of like
advertisement so I figured like any sort
of in May that game don't mean they get
the advertisement that friend yeah but
they also are being is a private
division owned by 2k mmm-hmm yes yeah
yeah that's that's a big firm to like
they got marketing dollars I mean they
make like a billion dollars off 1 2 K
game every time like you don't I mean
but the question is this right is how we
consume our stuff now so I can so mainly
most of my information through YouTube
right and through that consumption I'm
seeing the ads that pop up is out of
world people don't realize you know I
try to vocalize this enough it is not
worth advertising on TV unless it's
certain events or certain programs but I
worked for DISH Network
I was in these meetings like unless it's
the walking dead or Friday Night
Football or Monday night
there's more people watching YouTube
right now than the majority of programs
on TV by far remote sleep anytime you
see me on YouTube I'm sleep Rockets ever
all I wanted to get his take on this
situation you miss them yeah me I mean
yeah maybe I did you fill in bro um when
the news broke you know as far as this
whole thing without a world's like where
was your head at and then I'll see we
know about the
classification since then well I mean it
listen here's the thing it's funny I'm
not sure there might have been kids
moved that said it or it might actually
have been you it is really this
community and gaming journalism as a
whole is very funny go OK because if
this would have been roles reversed and
yes for with advancements people would
not have been calling foul especially in
the media I'm sorry I mean it is what it
is ok it would not have you wouldn't
have heard no one talking about it
except for the podcasters minute the
minute this was Microsoft's advantage it
it blew up like crazy now listen be
honest with you the X is more powerful
than the Pro I mean that's folks if you
haven't gotten that already let me write
it down give me any other threats now I
will break it down for you
boomstick style send it to you so you
can understand it it's it there's no
denying what it is it is what it is and
first of all the whole notion that the
evil the evil empire known as Microsoft
was going to somehow cut features from
media or the PlayStation pro version
just so the X looks better that that was
ridiculous oh I'm glad that was
clarified but I am going to say this
understand that when when King and I
talked about the long game that Phil is
playing this is a perfect example okay
so I'm sorry
it is Phil Maximus whence or Dominus max
so so so the thing is this he's playing
the long game and we also heard many
times over that when Phil Spencer went
to these companies and thought they were
currently working on they bought the
studios because of what they are working
on after but here is the trick outer
world is going to be a runaway success
there's no doubt about it and what they
have done is they put the bread crumbs
down to people that are starving and
when there are world's two releases and
it's an xbox a scarlet exclusive all of
these folks that play
the first one that are like well I'm not
going to play because it's on Xbox or
office because they're gonna be going
out and buying getting game pants or
getting a an Xbox scarlet console to
play it so not only is that important
mm-hmm but you have to understand it is
a Microsoft first party studio and I
would expect Sony because they're there
their dastardly right there the guy in
the corner watching a bomb exploding the
mustache so we got the photo super chat
from JV gamer a row talk can we please
go back to the pre 2002 definition of
triple-a you know when triple-a
representative quality and craftsmanship
of a game versus its budget look you
might be I really you know I I hate this
term triple-a like I really do I get it
people like to use that to clown all oh
it's just a dumb play yeah I can get an
86 Metacritic and if it wasn't a triple
like market it is a triple-a title it's
just a Doughboy though well that is good
I see so many people discrediting games
like Horry because it's just an oval
life it dead cells a triple a title in
your opinion no it's triple a quality
but it's not triple a budget okay so
might just want a good game I don't care
this okay so just like JD gave me saying
right
I don't equate it in that manner I don't
do the budget thing to say that it's
such a big budget because I'm gonna tell
you right now I cannot stand Red Dead
Anthony and they broke the budget but I
can play dead cells until I'm blue in
the face
and it's very hard to take this face and
make it blue alright so let's sum a
real-life chocolatey but I'm telling you
that game
zooms the qualities that I like in and
the care the craftsmanship the little
jokes the stuff here and there I'm
saying that read that doesn't have it
but read that budget was through the
roof and you had this game they gave me
the same amount if not way more
enjoyment out of a smaller budget but
that's a triple-a title as well I think
triple-a is defined by how that game
hits and resonates with the individual I
do have a question for you yes it turns
out of worlds I do feel like this is a
very very important title for Microsoft
in general like it might be an exclusive
but I feel like it can define what
obsidian can make for them in the future
yes what I like you know in terms of
critical acclaim what do you think like
an estimate of its Metacritic score
gonna be even 7 I think it's gonna be
like a like let's do three points like
three point estimate like I think it
took like an 83 till I can 86 I think
it's gonna be 92 to 96 the reason why I
listen the reason why I believe it's
gonna be that way is because it's going
to be on PlayStation now part two there
is only on xbox they're gonna be like
it's a 55 I guess it's just not
innovative enough it doesn't maybe think
it's previous didn't do you know I like
playing it on my 1440p screen arguably
to new vegas that's the best you know
anchorman is losing his mind right now
you know you'll say it's I think he says
it's the second I don't know I don't be
listen to increment now say hey I would
agree with you guys like Vegas
do they make fall on Vegas is the new
Vegas is the best of the Fallout games
it also made south more sticky truce you
know they made a pillars of
they make great games in that drawing
and they don't mess up like you're
always good right now he said this is
not a regular ILP episode this is xbox
where's the color Daniel I cannot read
you see the color addict addict I'm
color sensitive no I I do want to say to
booze playing about the because you know
I got a comment no I think this was a
media story because of what the
developer had previously stated I think
they did do
there was a Game Informer article long
like deep down dive into the developer
the game where the game informant did
speak to them and they said yeah yeah
they said hey you know what's gonna be
you know enhanced you know we want we
want this IP to be successful that's why
this was a story because all of
something we'll wait a minute like here
we are like three weeks from release and
now we're just finding out that it's not
gonna have enhancements when developer
previously said so I think that's why it
was a story I think isn't grab do you do
you like that is a huge biggest story
just because it's like three weeks out
and these news that they are set on
super enhancements oh you will not be in
this biscuit which you're mainly
thinking about thinking about is the the
only I care abouts a PC in hands what's
the other day but if you don't get a
biscuit with is it good me round' get my
biscuit my biscuits it's gonna have
biscuit in some butter so the millions
to 93 for me I think it's gonna be so
crazy I love how the game looks it looks
fantastic I'm sorry
I think 85 or C
some some some gameplays bridge it's on
the Swiss automatically had to give it a
little lowers oh wow yeah no I I think
oh my god I think 85 I see some gameplay
footage where the people work waiting
the shooting mechanics to fall off force
I'll deduct points for that there's some
there's some issues with the melee
combat not feeling responsive maybe
that's something they pass before leaves
but other than that I've heard the the
story arc the the character tree the
skill trees everything like that works
works for what I understand been really
awesome but in the chap what you guys
think is gonna get I want to Christopher
cuz of a heart you gotta you gotta give
us both versions the Xbox version and
the PlayStation version cuz you gotta
give me the 40 you know that used to
happen in the past you guys remember
that got more features they come with a
biscuit no biscuit for you we're gonna
get a biscuit we don't get apple pie
side dish baby anyway moving along oh oh
someone literally just said stalling on
that gifts baby so oh yeah man like a
lot is going on right now streets again
very hot and heavy in the womb
you know Gears five man MPD came out and
of course you boy had the article on
more the game with that net breaking now
the great Matt
piscatella information so um yeah man so
basically the news have come out you
know MPD and obviously md2k
20 has won MPD for September
[Music]
that's not like it should you know
Portland's three five four twenty and
then we were looking for kids as
obviously gears was a very highly
anticipated game a lot of hype behind it
and we saw that number seven was created
a lot of controversy in these streets
now on the Xbox platform itself it
finished third behind again NBA 2k and
or immortally actually bore lands led
first right correct okay so ball dance
was first on Xbox and NBA 2k 20 and then
gears was third on its own platform
mm-hmm
want to bring this to the Lord you know
I'm saying now in I wanted there's some
caveats here there's some things we got
to discuss um obviously you know with
the digital sales aspect in terms of
gears again on steam sales were not
counted for arm gears five for the Xbox
we know it's kind of new - um - MPD as
far as Microsoft kind of having their
games on that platform so I don't know
if it's something that will be
alleviated in the future but as of right
now the digital sales have come in so
I'm bringing this to the round table
you're all the streets are talking is
gears v a flap not even close not even
see it's not the millions say no well I
mean first of all you know here's the
problem the the the metrics that we are
currently forced to use are our
antiquated and old and it does not seem
like it makes a whole lot of sense when
when you talk about when you want to
talk about numbers it's funny because
you know you know you remember Beverly
Hills Cop to remember the part when they
were in the office about list of the
tickets and goes you know I don't
remember what's in this hand because the
$500 is in this hand right remember that
because I remember that me and my
brother Neal meant to talk a laugh about
that all the time it seems hilarious to
me that we have to we have to say before
we start talking about numbers this
wasn't added
and this wasn't it I mean come on folks
whoa I mean the NPD this is I'm sorry
folks
you guys need to spend some money and
update your system oh sorry I mean how
does first of all steam is the first is
the first time a major first party is on
there don't you think those numbers are
kind of important because I kind of do
and said I mean that's actually up the
self-esteem number that's not up to NPD
doesn't release digital numbers again
there's no power over that no no I I
hear yeah but what I'm saying is that
that's that's why we have to be careful
about how we how we put where we put
these numbers in these stories because
the numbers are not telling the story
yeah I agree that is the end of the
story and second of all we have to
remember this the fact that it hit
number seven because right don't think
that again people didn't talk about this
or I'm gonna bring it up the fact that
it's number seven in sales right with
certain numbers that are not being
counted because other people you know
with their dastardly in the corner with
my number seven out of the top ten games
and if in a title that's available for
free in game pass tells a better tale
than it being number seven because it's
not popular can we stop saying games and
game fashion for free you have to pay
subscription service for these younger
to me you're gonna love this because I'm
gonna pull no punches all right well I'm
gonna get ready I'm gonna get ready to
pass it over to he's usually okay well I
mean get back getting back to numbers
okay number three on the actual Xbox
platform folks Borderlands is a is both
both of those games NBA 2k 20 and
borderland Street or multi Platts votes
selling to millions more than just the
Xbox community so number three I gotta
be honest with you it's not bad no one's
damage controlling and I Got News for
you and this this is this is for the
PlayStation exclusive folks as much as I
love their exclusives and I talk about
their exclusives and their marketing
everything you need to stop fraud in you
get out there and buy yourself an Xbox
or play on PC and get yourself to play
gear fine
end of story and I'll let you go again
yes sir I'm Vito I gotta keep it fake I
keep my balance both sides making some
fantastic points first oh you are on
fire right yeah as far as the most our
plight aspect I feel good I'm saying now
the question I have for you because
remember NBA 2k I'm with you on that
more time than that and I spoke to shout
out to Matt piscatella I spoke to
piscatella behind the scenes because
technically switch does not count
digital sales no techno Tendo is
notorious for that
however with two cases the instructions
suck but with 2k I noticed the asterisk
on digital sales was not here for
Nintendo so I'm like is the switch sales
of 2k include and he said 2k I think the
thing is to publishers yes exactly the
publish which is always to take to
interactive whatever yes he confirmed
he's like cog that is also including
switch sales so that is huge for 2k to
do with it - it's getting basically all
those platforms okay Bourne Lance I'm
with you 5 foot we're gonna assume just
came out right you you're being Lords I
apologize FIFA legend of zelda links
awakening
zelda you know monumental IP i mean it's
a remake though there's a remake
but my my choppy that the only thing I
struggled and I got a ass bonus cuz made
some good points Maddon came out great
point came out one for one day and I was
the ultimate addition to be included
early on that list and his surprise gift
so a lot of the PlayStation contingents
a break point is inexcusable for break
point to be over gears because it was
only that was only the Ultimate Edition
yes it was multi player but it was only
one day available to hit I guess the
September mall what say you to those the
fan base they say that what I have to
say is that again you you're talking
multi-platform console that that that's
what I have to run with and it's not
damage controlling folks when you're
selling a game to multiple consoles or
or platforms to play on versus selling
one game to one group of gamers that did
I don't necessarily know if you can
argue the point
I'm not making an excuse if you say yo
Cobb that's those are multiplex at the
end of the day there's more people
there's no excuse
gears gears 5 didn't sell that much you
didn't sell like previous gears in this
that can be attributed to one thing
gamers yes yeah we don't know anybody
that bought that game remember what game
past you guys I just got one quick
question that we'll find out really what
happened King did you buy gate did you
buy this Reggie game I don't know ok
then right there if the past that was
done with dead listen Microsoft will
have me in the ecosystem I will never
let my past lapse I will never let my
game past lapse like I will never buy
another game
okay kids okay good tea okay kid is
cooking right now million users you know
on game path so like you and remember
with the if yeah game pads ultimate
which had just came out like a couple
weeks prior to like years I'm autumn it
really saying you got excess air early
so it's like this was one of those case
scenarios where game pass did it help
the cells of a game like you know how a
pass help yeah I see a and how it helps
thieves and whatnot vision now that the
the player base on game passes a little
bit mature they know what they're into
it it's just more so people gravitated
digs people that would have bought gears
for rightly yes poor thing sold over 650
copies during its release uh it's
initially so for his MBT MPD numbers
back in 2016 I'm going to tell you gears
5 probably did maybe 250 to 300 thousand
in actual actual cells but in-game pass
they still got the numbers that they
would have had as far as user so only
thing I gotta say it is it looks bad
because I read the way that we judge
everything in the way everything what we
measure success is oh it's so oh its
core that people into the day we got to
say hey how does my yourself look at
this like isnan work are they getting
what they want you by sacrificing gears
of wars unit cells versus a game past a
subscription um cells so that's where
I'm trying to figure out so cuz at some
point if gears is taking an L o this
they have to W somewhere else right so
Ryan smart points fire right now I gotta
give Spartan guard this one you coming
from K he said wait Microsoft said gives
game pass increases sales and Xbox dudes
claim dev said that their games did much
better on game pad so why no sales talk
ask the panel now what's up true
listen I'm a light your world on Friday
all you kid his own EBG
don't want kids don't want kids kids
saving the crap that he's prepping for
will continue a lot of the games like
the the games in game pass specially
like those mid tier game they're being
helped by game has there being like a
developer came out or did made the
descenders and he just revealed his
numbers of what impasse did so they just
came out like hey you know this is what
we did suspending game pass so I can
understand yes it does help games so
that statement still holds true but
that's thing is it true for every title
that falls in game pass
all right real quick I just want to
piggyback on what kid just said that
that is true because basically game past
is doing is resuscitating interesting
engaging those games that are very
release games I kept like a ninety 90
days shelf-life or something I think
Matt was telling us it's 90 days yeah
and after that it's like the fall-off is
like in terms of retail sales is
tremendous
well game Pass is doing what gets
talking about is resuscitating
engagement with people going out playing
those games and then buying them again
or doing micro transactions why not you
know I have a couple friends that
they'll get in a game pass and they'll
play a game for like two or three days
and then he gets took out a game past
and like well man now I gotta buy the
game never would have happened if they
they could play that game you know we
had a lot of discussions about this a
shout out to your rant man you had a
fantastic rant on this day ago my
question to you all prep is what about
again the contingent that says look at
gears for look at the contrast you know
I'm saying MPD of those I believe what
number three for that month yeah yeah so
I'm a friend i'ma let you roll with it
what do you say to that you know as far
as gears past history and this people
saying this is though the worst
gears has done the franchise is on a
decline in this game past thing is bad
for obviously giving it away like where
you at with that
so okay couple things um yeah the optics
I could see that argument I don't agree
I don't think first of all I don't think
gears isn't decline gears v was a better
game than gears for in my opinion I
think there's a lot of stuff we don't
know in terms of the numbers like what
did gears 5 do for game has clearly
Microsoft's focus on engaged
the focus on game pass you know I ran
has said this on numerous occasions on
this podcast that he's been to pull
directly that they don't care about
selling physical discs or you know
digital downloads they care about game
path subscriptions they want to sell
game pad subscription so they don't care
about you know if they sold three
million at retail they did they just
don't they they're not they're not
focused on that yeah but you know the
optics of it I can understand this
argument if you look at Gears of War for
in 2016 MPD it was number three overall
for that month it sold to a smaller
install base and pbut MPD back then
wasn't reporting digital sales so this
was all physical sales for Gears of War
for it came in number three big releases
for that month were battlefield one
mafia three titanfall 2
I think FIFA 17 NBA 2k it released a
month before so it finished three and
then it finished number one for the Xbox
platforms for that month so yeah I mean
is I think what like and I agree with
Kidd said the I think the obvious here
is that game paths had an impact on
retail sales for Gears 5 now does it
mean that that because didn't you know
chart number 3 like Gears of War 40 that
it's in decline I'm not gonna make that
argument because I think there's so many
things we don't know did did Gears 5
drive higher subscription rates and did
Microsoft get more people locked into
you know game pass that's the end goal
for them we don't know that information
let me share a coke or so we got for our
super chat from a Philly I says for
everyone 10 million users for a hundred
million cells it's just the same as 3
million users from 40 million cells I'm
pretty good at math is busted a cars at
each other in this chat so parkour yup
I'm thoroughly entertained by them too
but could take your wrap no bugs Philly
and I really can't see you you like the
tree and winning with the cable breath
oh I need to do because smart guy I'm
not gonna let him die out like this but
questions Martin you're falling off but
question is what about his point that yo
is kind of spooky that they won't
Microsoft won't reveal those said
engagement numbers and those said you
know subscriptions millions many things
are not as bright they may not be I mean
and you know I that's I I when they when
they switch to the percentage things
that's why I tweeted out that you know I
have one Apple you know this year I
added another Apple and I grew 50% or
whatever under it so yeah no II don't
know it does raise eyebrows and you can
argue the optics of it being good or bad
but it does for me raise eyebrows like
what's we're we're never gonna know I
think that's the bottom so Devils don't
brag they can fly I was talking to Matt
- Matt notes around massonetti a pass
has you stumped like he even said it
matt said you know in the early days a
game pass he said was clear that sales
were held particularly games like c at
these when she talked about say dk2 he
said that might still be true but he
said it also may not he's like daily he
said the data current leads me to no
strong hypothesis either way now so you
know even he's gonna like it's a flute
situation exactly so we don't know what
what i'm curious is is is obviously
there's a decline in retail sales
yes i don't think anyone can argue that
there is and and and that's that's the
part of the game past effect now is
microsoft taking a hit on this game now
like are they okay with losing the $60
retail sale at giving away a game at $14
a month or like our case like lord king
says a dollar you know one buck how did
in my question is
his how sustainable is that you know I
don't have an answer for that that's my
question
let me can they sustain it well I well
just say I think that the way they
sustain that is by increasing the
numbers of subscriptions and we know
that Netflix is at issues with with that
in money I think people have you
suggested that their model kit isn't
sustainable when you think about how
much money they put an exclusive content
versus how much to bring in terms of
subscriptions so so we'll see that's
that's the big unknown question mark
yeah alright so you know popcorn yeah
yeah y'all dudes right okay so let me
give you for the for the guys that's
against it right
the guys that against it they tell you
man they tell you god of war
spider-man they selling these numbers
they women MPD's you know King you gotta
understand man they all have moving
units that's what your company focuses
your company focus isn't on the future
your company focuses right now we need
to line our pockets right now can we not
may not be here tomorrow so we got to
get all that money from these dudes
right now now let me ask you a question
if you have the same ability to play it
in PlayStation now date and date which
you went out and brought it or would you
brought PlayStation now would you have
grown your service or would you sat
there and just purchase the game
outright me personally I ought to
purchase PlayStation now and I'll play
God of War for the buck or whatever it
would have been for the that
subscription we had the front line right
and at the front line for these frauds
take it out no you gotta understand boom
they're not keeping the same energy
y'all wanted me to keep the same energy
and keep the same energy at no point in
time were they gonna be out to K and
Borderlands do you know why because you
had the hard car that was going for
Borderlands and you had the cash that
was going for 2k and then in 2k was
definitely gonna get the casual so
they're coming into three behind those
two I will definitely like to run that
race I would definitely like to come in
three they didn't come in for they came
behind to juggernut you gotta tell me
Borderlands 3 was not one of the most
anticipated games in it yeah I was
sitting in the conference when you're
just sitting there waiting for the for
real to get done
and nobody complaining that one time not
no outrage nobody walked out they said
any took it
I see duels on 2k I'm talking about real
live boobs that come off the street run
and get they 2k digital download and buy
like $400 you wanna tell me that gear
you gonna beat that no Microsoft said
you know what we we're not gonna sit
there and act like we're gonna win this
but to come in free on your own platform
that's fantastic the coming seventh
overall that's insane one engagement
numbers is definitely not none of your
business
let me let me explain one and no point
in time is the engagement down because
you can get a match every time you get
in you're not sitting there waiting
around if you got game Pass or if you
got gears and you know that you're gonna
go play multiplayer right now see they
don't have to worry about it no more
that if you play the single player
you're not gonna stick around it's in
game past brah so your friend tell you
hey you wanna play some gears right now
let's play some gears right now let's
play some co-op let's do that it's in
there from dating date you don't have to
worry about that you know what that does
that gives you a portfolio you know when
you go to your stock markets and you go
to your bonds and they open your
portfolio up and it Shaun Disney they
show in Microsoft is showing me my sunny
you don't want that in there Google they
shown you Amazon they show you these
people that send your portfolio these
high-powered stuff this is how you sell
your portfolio to people alright so all
these high-powered games is inside game
pass this is moving forward so if you
never got a chance to play gears guess
what happens when that new person comes
to get game pass engagement numbers is
gonna stay the same because a new person
has just purchased into the ecosystem
what do you think that person is gonna
go to first
those Microsoft games that they didn't
have before that is free right there
that they don't have to go out to the
store and purchase it is there okay so
now let's get down to the crux of it cuz
you guys are sitting here with this
weird old energy they're coming in
third behind Borderlands if if you had
to bet $1,000 and I'm gonna ask you
fraud guys that's in it because if you
lie I'm gonna hit you alright so this is
what are you fraud this in there
you play 2k you can buy gears first you
got $1,000 to bet if he was going to bet
you knew it was gonna come in not first
not second in that month you're a little
games that was coming out Microsoft
would have bet against that there's no
way we beat Borderlands it wasn't gonna
happen
mmm he orders along told you what was
gonna go down but what America people
kick that's a we settle it it's like
Stockholm Syndrome we accept you wanna
fight for first place we could easily
won first place just launched in a month
that there's no games
silly was coming out and they said so
what they saw listen that's like going
into a fistfight and you know Mike Tyson
is one of the combatants you know what
Michael looked at him I said I'm not
really afraid of you
so after they launched into caves when
you want to the next 2k any o it in game
past that's what I'm gonna play so
basically coming
you don't say a couple of rail with it
but Microsoft's doing the long game
because they gonna be around say
Microsoft wants you to get game pass all
right I don't don't get it twisted if
I'm gonna tell you right now y'all guys
know that new head of Sony don't show
the key inside PlayStation now he
wouldn't cut the price and he wouldn't
told y'all your first party games are
gonna be in there biscuit to
got a biscuit this might be your boss
epic Sunday rain ever Susan he warned
everyone that he was gonna be blowing up
some spots and I think he did that with
this weirdo energy because listen I got
a Playstation if they told me right now
that date and date day joints is coming
um-um put my credit card in I'm gonna
pray for the 3-year package I don't
think anybody would debate that if a PS
now offered games day and date first
party I don't think I wouldn't complain
I don't think anybody would complain how
could you what are cheering that there
there are a limited time by the breath
if they took if they told you they did
they were doing that you have somebody
arguing the fact that it's a great thing
now why now why not because it's
everybody loves it when it's your team
that's why with your team it's like the
Yankees they just lost right I can't
believe it
I said stop it stop it right now you
want a head the better piss on the
Astros do you know the Astros is a
better grinding team and the Yankees was
doing one way right so you had to
understand that if used on bet your
money just Tully's dues a bet they money
when it comes to betting money then you
see the real like all this Xbox in-game
past slander the story of Xbox Xbox /
game passing P PlayStation star
traditional console reminds me of the
story of the rabbit and the turtle with
PlayStation being the rabbit think it's
all thinking it's already one day don't
Wow the shroom digging them with the two
dollars in which a king hit him with
[Laughter]
don't forget remember film Maximus
Dominus Spencer does everything for a
purpose the end game being so since it's
only 60 under game passes the truth
given by Phil all right now I don't I
want y'all to be I want you to
understand this I don't know everything
Phil once only gone no you know what he
wants them to do the ultimate let me you
know what the thing that y'all really
don't want to see when that sony logo up
up and at the bottom is an icon to click
on gamepad I'm gonna tell you right now
when it happens y'all better get all
four Twitter y'all better run and hide
from me because I will seek each and
every last one of you out and I'm gonna
put a real fraud alert on you you know
kind you know you know what this sounds
like this sounds like when the azure
deal was done the the fine print said
that every time you launched Sony
product using Azure servers it's gonna
have that little xbox game paste studio
you know what I could see that happening
one day I just want to just on a live
chat like Christopher Hart says King is
all about rental services now like I
don't understand this argument about
rental services like I don't you gay
pastor the rental service it's a value
add it's a value added service yeah and
I never understand why people argue
services are things that benefit
consumers like
you know like I don't have to buy gears
five now and save me $60 it's more money
I can use sort something else buy
another game or I'm gonna buy you know a
game for my PC so channa with the $2 to
dr. pounds super check so little brother
please say something please say that we
want to hear your words Oh hold on I
just got a dress you don't even though
that color shot today the lord of the
realm obg he is like Yoda turtle the air
race he was like the game been over for
him the whistle blew went to the locker
room got you said I talked about the
long game the game well you went to the
locker room and then boom he ran past
you smoothie Wow so next year when you
launch and y'all gotta buy those games
for that PlayStation and the Bucks
adding up and I'm going to go get my
system with the $1 super jet nothing
like a hundred games sitting there
talking about we got nothing this month
is just nothing else just wow yeah we're
going to see what we think what's
interesting about all this is you know
laughing and joking about you know game
passing everything and PlayStation now
but I think one thing that I've noticed
is that it doesn't seem like this maybe
run one right way to do business in the
gaming industry now it seems like the
pies gotten so big now then you can have
companies like Google with stadia and
microsoft word game pass and nintendo
who's really sticking to their guns with
traditional let's say console gaming if
you will that they're all they all could
potentially be successful I think that's
the fascinating thing about where the
gaming industry is now for where it was
when we first started getting like 37
years ago you know there was one way to
do it 30 years ago now seems like
there's different ways of doing it and
that's that to me just fascinating it
speaks to the growth of the gaming
industry you know what's gonna work it
was
but not clearly Marcus all fat let me
jump there's a phone um you know clearly
Marcus off has a strategy and it's kind
of what you've been saying rap it's kind
of like that whole you know short-term
short-term sales versus the long-term
you know engagement in subscriptions
right and we don't know we don't know
what is gonna work but it's clear
Microsoft is invested this way really
it's clear that they are willing to take
the short-term sales loss where the
gears meeting at at number seven or
whatever provided that it's not you know
I'm saying it's not gonna be at the top
of MPD to get you in the ecosystem
because the argument remember when we
first heard was like yo they giving it
away
it's $2.00 game and I was enrolled yeah
but stuff like you know so I can't front
kid like it is impressive to me that
it's even number in the top ten you
don't say it to be honest because yep
that's great point just get to it right
now there's a lot of game with this
pocket watching little me and then where
I come from I don't watch the next man
pocket I'm doing what's best for me yes
bro I don't go to the dealership when I
go get the range and be like y'all I
don't know y'all 40% off this top pocket
watching let's do what's best for the
gamer for yourself if you got two
dollars and you want to play Gears 5 you
do it now will that affect sales yes but
according to Microsoft they don't care
they wants you in that ecosystem the way
they look at it just like the casual guy
who buys in efforts you know many people
buy Netflix and say yeah I should cancel
my joint and then you watch something
else and then you engage with something
else I'm not canceling my membership
model
I just keep forgetting to cancel it and
it just keep reoccurring everybody you
know EA access they trying to do and the
last point I'm gonna make is like we're
not gonna act like steam is not a factor
here stayin is the number one de-facto
PC platform and that wasn't included so
we got a defend them on there we gotta
say yo you know that's another thing
that possibly could have boosted the
sales up that's all I gotta say man we
got it
stop pocket watch when they tell you
that something there's something is
saving you money all right I didn't have
to pay $60 for that so you know what I
did I brought my Zelda so yeah but
listen to this let me give you another
little nugget
please Nintendo do game pass on so I can
save money and buy pizza you bought you
buy more statues we understand what the
scripture model to money but they want
us to believe
GAE pass is bad when it saves you money
and you can play mad games I know the
poor are simple but stop dude before you
move on to the next topic I
unfortunately have to go cuz I have to
help the missus I want to thank
everybody first of all I want to thank
Chad you guys are like always
first of all outstanding to watch a lot
of lot of heat today a lot of heat but
you know what as long as you keep it
respectful he is good you know I'm
saying cuz everyone has an opinion
everyone's opinion counts remember that
folks everyone's opinion does count it
may not go with what you are believing
but you gotta respect the opinion and
and if someone's being disrespectful
then then that's right out the window
but um I'm gonna thank for the everyone
thank you for the invite dude hanging
out with everyone on here I love all you
guys this is just something I look
forward to each and every time we get
together and I'll see you guys the next
time you're next and you know I'm one of
these
we'll do it from the beginning which was
the game I know I saw that see that's
how you know that this show in its host
is biased towards you literally you
literally name the witcher 3 and all its
greatness which i don't play that game
for this beside the point see the
switcher 3 you know shelter saw he could
big him but he had this great topic i
know i didn't even know apparently
modders have gotten ahold of it and have
unlocked sixty frames per second on that
blow-up is documented footage you know
say so you know according to solve he
thinks this is very focusing on
Nintendo's part he feels that you know
that maybe
she's holding back so the fact that they
hit that that benchmark you know the
question I'm gonna bring to the realm
you know do you agree with this
mentality by Nintendo or do you say you
know what maybe they're doing it for
another reason not to whether they have
to shut off to get it again is it you
know how much resolution we already low
as it was sacrifice and do you blame the
Tendo for not allowing dev to get
maximize power switch starve a kid oh me
oh I'm still shocked that even we should
eat I'm putting that game morning sweet
oh no from what I saw look like freakin
on wish you call it um what's that game
one in Nintendo 64 dog like starfox how
much do they charge good look know your
kid with the Nintendo sales tax they
charge you to extra foolish text is
degress the Vaseline charge grease now
the screen what you say okay just to be
clear you're saying they're charging the
millions to put that best I don't know
about all that millions
but yeah maybe so maybe so cuz you know
if your sovereign and you know Cognito
know the actual sales numbers I don't
know I think it's just just to say oh we
got it is for bragging rights and stuff
like that but um honestly um you said
the question was do you feel Newton was
wrong for holding devs back yeah is that
is that what came out or is that we're
going because you should never topic of
you buddy you could take away we want to
take you just I think um Nintendo should
do everything they can't for like to
allow dev to like unleash the power of
their console if it has it so if I if
it's if it was a good showing of the
game running at 60 because I didn't see
it running at 60 frames per second and
whatnot then um yeah I fly open the lid
but um
and it's a very important question is
are you are you called arguably the
worst system you can't tell me that
combat system is good to switch based on
fencing is really defense based on
fencing
yes you should put it in a box and mail
it away don't put a fence in front of it
[Music]
[Music]
even three frames is it what things I
think there's one thing to say it runs
at 60 does it run at 60 consistently
easy you know and like cake like like
kids said like what do they have to
sacrifice you know what should
interesting in the body switch it is
possible to mod the Nintendo switch to
allow sound from the PC version that's
avoiding the compressed default sound
and it's possible to unlock the PC
settings and luring pieces I rap rap
acts that question again what did they
sacrifice accident sacrifice to get in
running 60 frames a second they did
everything
[Laughter]
the switch on the switch considering how
big it is not beyond console
so anyway runs like crap and know
whatever what man it's miracle are sad
aren't works period but that's because
the developers no CD partner already pug
G on a switch young listen art on the
art addict located they was gonna do
this I know they was gonna do this they
were gonna stop badgering it first and
then it was gonna turn out but you know
it's a technical feat and now imminent
end only hits that game scope with that
game brandy game I mean look we get Joe
could say you know it looks like
minecraft but I mean all Joey decided me
for them to put that game to make a
switch point to something and I'm gonna
tell you why you're onto something and
father Nintendo knows best if father
Nintendo told you you can't go 60 stop
trying to be a fast boy okay trying to
go 60 by turning down the sound into
some weirdo realm
stop stop hacking your switches letting
father Nintendo guide you in the ways of
playing on a switch now listen we all
buy a switch to be held in switches and
turn them into speed you know what
happened blows up get all these games on
the switch I'm gonna make Lego editions
of everything you said Jonathan b7
cyberpunk hit the switch when cyberpunk
hit the switch internal I forgot that
cyberwar
in the switches to explode in people's
hands I'll be holding that game playing
the juggernaut back there with the big
bulky hands even to even play it because
if it blows up
I will say this a young defense you know
say it seems interesting that he
actually could do it I was actually
impressed that he could even do 60 but
he's got to be a technical reason
because that GPU with SC that lets me
run it you know it's probably not safe
to do one thing about Nintendo is they
are very critical when it comes to
battery life get up for that's gonna get
into the into the title screen that's as
far as its what was the foot it was a
samsung phones Catching Fire
I was at the galaxy uh no prototype it
was a galaxy notes they was blowing up
anyway
with the September MPD results of gears
fire finishing number seven overall and
number three on the Xbox one in dollar
sales do you consider this a sale flop
for the gift franchise the choices are a
yes Xbox flagship franchise cannot crack
top three MPD nor number one on its own
platform
be no game pass is a success and it's
still in the top ten without steam sales
or C I don't care I'm copping anything
for one dollar subscription IOP poll
later this week salute to all the lords
and Lords boomstick X out and of course
my man bro lab rap in the round holding
us down answer the call it started off
with Lord
once again King we get neglected we
didn't listen we were here we were next
week next week you just go see me key
not here we are the Lord so Lord Lord
breath first bed thank you for answering
the call brother what do you got going
all wicked if I don't find it yeah man
well I just want to say first of all any
time you guys need me let me know
you know if I can make it I will be
there and look a great show by the way
series a great topics great conversation
obviously you guys know I'm a big fan of
the show I try to tune in every Sunday
try to keep things entertaining the a
live chat but yeah everyone you guys can
find me on Twitter at Bram or podcast
and you can find us on YouTube based on
where the Eric a podcast we but we
podcast live every Wednesday night at 9
p.m. Eastern Standard Time and I'm known
to drop a rain or two maybe during the
week as well so gentlemen seriously it's
been a pleasure and yeah we got a few
guys back on braaap it's been a long
time and I want to say something real
quick - hashtag pcmasterrace ask that
hashtag I already have scarlet I just
want to say if you have not destiny to
on PC you are you are robbing yourself
of a great gaming experience lose 10
viewers like a medium a Cox Tim Street
man I was playing iron banner last night
man and blown away blown away it's just
a different experience man it really is
for none of y'all I got the same piece
yeah I got all it I'm not doing it to
myself I love my friends my shout out
the mez PC master race boyz mo said rap
got picked up a British accent as soon
as he got his refresh likes man 105
people when you get that like let's get
over really appreciate Jonathan B that
was a fire intro cog I'm ready for the
shoulder yo you stupid
got the kids move in a minute good to
see you brother what's going on with you
man um quiet but um I you know I've been
streaming a whole lot one mixer so
please follow me there mixer calm / I am
kids move on I'd be streaming almost
every day honestly that's right go with
min to get them books yeah I still do
thing on YouTube best spot theories you
know Laura no solo show I do like once a
week at least it's been looking like
that but um now just chillin make sure
you subscribe you know
please razz me I love to be on the show
need to do one more of those really try
hard games because I'm gonna tell you
right now I can not eat watching you do
that I can outdrink watching you do that
I can't I have anything that I gotta go
to bathroom with watching you do that
because you are probably the funniest
dude on YouTube right now we fell over
the bed I fell off the bed or something
no no that would be a reasonable blood
boy stream like screaming his when he
threw that controller and I saw a set
off the motion since the second part was
[Music]
funny is save like you can save videos I
saved the marks moving ability I'm gonna
rose but we gonna get around table with
the laws I mean why are not we gonna get
that brother in there you already know
but up yeah the Lord's so happy to have
the Lords
on Twitter and you can catch me at
YouTube might hopefully my piece to be
fixed you soon you can catch me there
now I don't know if you'll catch me next
week on IOP yet you know we'll have to
see how the strike goes first for the
Twitter you know I'm sure there'll be
some type of negotiation terms on there
and I definitely you know I want to take
a second appreciate everyone that came
by I appreciate all the likes that
everyone did appreciate all the super
chests you know they definitely helped
the podcast tremendously and uh you know
you might see you next week or not we
don't know that do you guys like have
the big inflatable rat in front of my
car if they go on strike just call me
man now we have scab agencies pleasure
premium talk was in the building
letting the realm know about that every
day that gets all that flatness where
could I find people find what you got
going on sir
what's going on y'all can catch me on
Twitter King David OTW that's of the
world and not the way also you can catch
me at lords of gaming dotnet where you
can go to the iron Lords tab and you can
pull up king of the statues we the
juggernaut do like yeah
and big statue y'all seeing statues in
the past has been behind me that dude is
ginormous wait man it's pretty heavy I
think it weighs Oh of that statue with
his background and also watch the video
oh you know oh no any no what now rocker
put it he I can put it on the rotator
because that can carry up to 80 pounds
the only thing is I was a bit hesitant
in the fact that how he's leaning
forward no I want to jostle him around
like that um because it would be
spinning and it's not the won't be going
fast but back there that can actually
sustain the weight and turn it you know
from side to side he needs to get a
statue of himself made oh you know what
I don't have one commissioned listen I
want you guys to really understand that
we do this as a labor of love and you
know we bring this energy for you
because I'm dead tired in the morning I
come from work and I probably get like
half an hour worth of sleep and I get
back on the show but if I can if I can
see dizzy going through the stuff that
he's going through and he's staying here
from start to finish and he's in given
all his energy and he's given me that
energy to keep going is like
Hulkamaniacs I felt like he has me
shaking the ropes like the undone the
ultimate warrior this man gives me
energy to go forward alright understand
he is a true hero and y'all need to go
to the the GoFundMe I don't care if it's
a dollar I'll go to his Twitter give him
a shout-out talk to him speak them keep
his spirits up keep everything going for
him because listen that guy is truly an
inspiration he should be an inspiration
to everyone in this room
absolutely man like I said solo to the
community for all pulling together you
know we're trying to do something for
DES you know
tweeting and keeping his spirits up like
I said we we all time everybody's got
you know jobs and life gets in the way
but we come do this for y'all we enjoy
I'll make us laugh even when you
disagree with us here and I had to put
up a whole front like ad it was sick he
was like you know saw he's got stuff
going on too so we really supreme
supreme and this is this is love like I
said that's a crazy away from me with
some real quick we are working on the
membership thing yes so keep that in
mind
I know clue that's gonna be up because
we don't want to just throw it up we
wanted to actually have value to the
people that are doing it so you know
definitely look out for that and we
definitely gonna have that filled
ominous Maximus Spencer shirts you
understand you're gonna get that dead
lovely laugh right now like
we gotta have a emote with the millions
billion we got we gotta have that yo
they order something with some colors
how about the real pill can get that
hello that's Phil bogus you can get you
got it
[Laughter]